if you know us you know we love Disney
and we can never stop singing Disney
songs but did you know that the lyrics
come with plenty of metaphors and hidden
meanings wait until number one because
you'll never look at Mother Gothel in
the same way don't forget to give this
video a thumbs up and subscribe to the
things now let's check out 10 hidden
messages in Disney songs descendants
before we get on to actual lyrics and
other shenanigans let's take a look at
descendants it turns out their musical
numbers reveal plenty of things you've
probably never noticed before let's be
honest descendants have some of the best
musical and dance numbers ever and they
could only be beat by the next Disney
movie but before we move on to that
let's focus on hidden messages have you
noticed that one of the descendants
musical numbers actually reveals a
secret detail shout out to oh my des nee
comm for pointing this out if Yuri watch
the rotten to the core performance
you'll notice that it reveals a little
hidden message about our favorite
villains you'll need to pay attention to
the background and all the signs we see
first of all the fact that live spells
evil backwards is just so fitting for
this movie and when Eevee first comes
out you can see a yellow sign that
Fried's hooks clock and Curiosity Shop
say what does that mean hairy hook was
part of the first dissonance movie and
we didn't even know when the crew is
doing their dance break you could also
see signs for gaston's duels without
rules and fro bows creepy era are these
just a coincidence or will we eventually
learn more about these places High
School Musical High School Musical might
have ended a few years ago but that
doesn't mean that fans don't come up
with new theories about the movies
itself and of course messages and songs
this one was pretty obvious to any true
fan but in case it went over your head
if we have an interesting theory with a
hidden message for you do you remember
the second movie with the baseball scene
featuring Ryan and Chad Chad was singing
a song titled I don't dance but we all
know that this is not true because Chad
even danced in the first movie so what
was this actually about
some suspect that there might be a
hidden message of a secret romance in
that song the songs pretty catchy but
you should also pay attention to the
choreography and what's happening with
the two characters chat clearly states
he doesn't dance but goes as far as
saying that while he's actually dancing
during the song say what some think that
the actual message in the song is Ryan
and Chad's slowly accepting their
romantically fond of each other by the
end of it we see them both dancing in
the final scene the two are seen wearing
each others clothes don't actual couples
do that The Lion King
we love The Lion King and be prepared is
one of the most awesomest songs in the
movie it's one of the best villain songs
ever but the song could have been played
out differently if Disney ended up
adding deleted lyrics be prepared is all
about scar putting together his plan to
end Mufasa 's life and take the power of
the pride the entire song is pretty dark
and gruesome but what can you expect
from someone like scar but did you know
that the Lion King the musical has a
song called the madness of Kings scar
that's even creepier than be prepared it
was originally supposed to be in the
movie but it got cut and some of the
lyrics got altered for the Broadway show
probably because it featured plenty of
messages that will never make you see
scar in the same way if you haven't
heard it you really should the lyrics
include scar saying things like my
cylinders firing with fervor and you my
sweet thing with the part which is
clearly an innuendo that's definitely
not meant for kids in this deleted movie
scene he also states that knowledge
should be prepared for a stunning
proposal because power and beauty should
bond yeah we're kind of glad this got
deleted Aladdin speaking of
inappropriate songs some people seem to
think that there's a hidden innuendo in
everyone's favorite Aladdin song how
could you not love a whole new world
it's a magical song that takes you back
to the childhood Disney days every time
you hear it but is there a hidden
metaphor in a whole new world something
it's an innuendo that's way too
inappropriate for kids and we feel like
we don't even have to say it out
but the magic carpet ride lyrics has
caught I did those that are quick to
point out any lyrics that might relate
to inappropriate innuendos and
shenanigans if you ignore the characters
backstory and see this song without a
context it might as well have a hidden
meaning after all Aladdin wants to show
Jasmine a whole new world and open her
eyes of course you should take this
hidden meaning with a grain of salt but
it's been noted that Disney loves to
intentionally and unintentionally add a
new windows to the lyrics and after
hearing that deleted scar song were
really not surprised that a whole new
world could have a completely different
meaning but let's just pretend these are
just mere theories because no one will
ruin our favourite Disney song
reflection here's an interesting one
depending on the perspective Disney
songs might have plenty of hidden
meanings and reflection is definitely a
proof of that when you look at it within
context it talks about Mulan having an
inner battle of fiddy men or going with
what her heart wants but the truth of
the matter is reflection could also be
an important LGBTQ anthem as its hidden
meanings could very well resonate with
the community that's still largely not
accepted in some parts of the world
Mulan even asks herself if she's not
meant to play the part of a bribed or a
daughter since she can't be perfect she
also says that if she was her true self
it would break her family's heart which
again is an issue plenty of LGBTQ teens
struggle with she also says that she
can't hide who she is even though she
tried which is just heartbreaking
even a simple line of wondering why her
reflection isn't someone she recognizes
resonates with a lot of teens that can't
be themselves whether it's because of
their gender sexuality or anything else
we love reflection for what we love even
more is that that song could have so
many hidden meanings depending on your
personal struggles Alice in Wonderland
we don't talk much about Alice in
Wonderland on this channel but we'll
make an exception for this hidden
message that's actually pretty gruesome
if you think about it remember the
walrus and the carpenter'
we eventually learn what happened to the
little oysters that were just too
curious
the song is pretty upbeat
are you listening to the lyrics the
walrus actually ate the little oyster
babies it's even sadder when the little
oysters that are still alive and shown
on screen get instantly scared when they
see walrus coming down
he even tricks them into going on a walk
with him even though we all know that it
would end catastrophic Lee the walrus
was also clearly interested in just the
kids since he paid no attention to the
mom how bizarre Lee inappropriate of a
Disney character to have such a strong
wish to eat young oysters the song is
also an important message to listen to
what your mom says and not go with
strangers no matter how charming they
might seem we have to admit we always
get sad whenever we watch that scene
because the hidden message of the walrus
wanting to eat the oysters is just
heartbreaking Beauty and the Beast have
you ever heard of Beauty and the Beast
the enchanted Christmas it's a video
sequel to the original Disney movie and
while it might not have been as popular
as the original it definitely reveals
some unexpected things about Forte the
pipe organ unlike most of Beauty and the
Beast songs this one almost resembles
the Grinch especially with the song
called don't fall in love we've heard
plenty of Disney songs that warn the
characters about the dangers of falling
in love and having your first heartbreak
but Forte takes it to a new level and
maybe that's the reason why you can only
get this movie on video at the first
glance Forte is clearly warning the
beasts about falling in love with Belle
but apart from the usual warnings for
teen manages to squeeze in a brilliant
line that has a hidden meaning he says
that a beast is turned on he should just
turn off her that's a very clear
subliminal message but since it wasn't
air to me original Beauty and the Beast
most people don't even know it exists
but maybe that's for the better
considering the young audience of these
movies should never know what Forte
actually meant as being turned on frozen
but enough about being inappropriate
we apologize in advance if this will
make you get the let it go songs stuck
in your head for the rest of the day but
there's one hidden message
we need to discuss let it go is all
about letting things go and not being
held back by your own fears but
depending on the point of view this
message might even be deeper than you
think
psychologists have noted that frozen and
let it go in particular can resonate
with those that suffer from mental
illnesses they stated that their
behavior resembles else's behavior at
the beginning of the movie while there
might be many mental health services
available the majority of people often
hide away from their family just like
Elsa did in her let it go song Elsa even
describes a swirling storm inside which
could relate to the complex emotions a
person with a mental illness might feel
and then there's of course the
empowerment part of the song that talks
about accepting yourself with all your
flaws while the context of that song
could relate to any one of many suspect
but it holds a hidden message that
directly speaks to people with mental
illnesses into the woods we never get to
talk about into the woods but who could
possibly forget about this astounding
Disney movie it doesn't hurt that it
comes with some of our favorite songs
either it turns out almost every song
and into the woods is a metaphor with a
hidden message including the woods
itself it's a metaphor for an unknown
challenge as the woods is often
incredibly dark and gets you easily lost
the story talks about overcoming many
challenges by not giving in to the fear
of unknown the song children will listen
has an interesting hidden message of
warning parents about the hidden power
that comes with parenting in general the
lyrics also connect to Stephen
Sondheim's own personal battles he
endured with his mother who let's just
say wasn't exactly a nice person it's
also been noted that songs like I know
things now talk about much more than
just a regular encounter between the red
riding-hood and the wolf even Jack and
the Beanstalk has a hidden message of
lost innocence it's also noted that
songs like I know things now talk about
much more than just a regular encounter
between Red Riding Hood and the
it's always been said that into the
woods was meant for adults more than it
was meant for children which is why all
of these subliminal messages might
actually make a lot of sense
tangled tangled is arguably one of the
cutest modern Disney movies but it comes
with plenty of flaws and hidden messages
you've probably never even noticed no
one really likes Mother Gothel but
there's more to her than you might think
some van suspect that she has a
narcissistic personality disorder as
many fans have resonated what that looks
like with their own parents although
mother knows best is incredibly catchy
it's the lyrics that give people
goosebumps many have pointed out that
Mother Gothel isolates her child in the
same way I'm narcissistic mother does
she also presents a false image of
herself including telling Rapunzel that
she knows best when the truth is she
really doesn't
the entire scene shows her tricky
Rapunzel into making her think she can
do this but at the same time scarring
her until Rapunzel finally realizes she
should stay in the tower no matter what
it's a trait that's shared by many
narcissistic parents who never let their
children go up and see the life outside
of their family values while this might
have a few benefits it can be incredibly
harmful and mother knows best as well as
tangled gives a clear indication of the
narcissistic side of Mother Gothel and
that's all for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things and tell us how
you felt about this video thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]